we start with that breaking news from
Niger where at least 17 soldiers have
been killed in an ambush the military
leadership says that its troops were
attacked by an armed group near the
tillaberry region it also said its
forces killed several of the fighters
Ahmed Idris is in the Nigerian town of
katsina that's near the border with
Niger Ahmed this broke just a few
moments ago what do you know at this
early stage
well is it continuous continue of the
violence we see on the Niger
Malin and Niger Burkina Faso border this
attack happened uh days after another
one that killed several
Nigerian soldiers on the border with
Burkina Faso so it looks like the whole
thing is spreading faster now that's
that's one of the main concerns of
security analysts in the region about
the continuing growth of cools in the
region if you look at Mali and Burkina
Faso despite the presence of mercenaries
like Wagner on their territory they
still continue to face attacks from
these armed groups Allied to Al-Qaeda
and isil that have been operating in
that region for a long time and now with
this current attack this is a fifth
attack by the way in less than three
weeks since the coup in Nigeria Republic
and the more these continue to go on the
last credible the statement by the
military authorities in Nigeria that
they have overthrown Muhammad simply
because of the deterior rating security
situation in Nigeria so it's undermining
their credibility as a force or as a as
a unit or as a government to fight
insecurity in the region that's the
concern of many people there are people
especially security analysts who think
that the continuing spread of cools in
the region will embolden armed groups
and that is what we continue to see
since the coup in Mali and then the coup
in Burkina Faso as well now Niger is
suffering the same fate Ahmed it Bears
repeating this fundamental point that
you made that this late is coup and it
was the case with previous coups in Mali
as well this latest coup was
um
uh Justified
officially on the premise that the now
deposed president had not done a good
job of fighting the Insurgent groups and
as you rightly pointed out there have
been multiple attacks since the coup
took place do we know if the Junta has
changed anything to its military
Readiness or to its tactics to
effectively fight these insurgents
groups
I think rather than improve the security
situation it has even gotten worse
remember the Americans and the French
have been training French forces
especially the Americans but with the
suspension of such uh partnership or
agreements with the Nigerian forces it
makes life a lot more difficult it will
be difficult for Niger now to source for
equipment which is also the Weaponry to
deal with the rising cases of attacks by
these armed groups in the Sahel and then
of course the the concern is that Niger
doesn't have enough resources to go and
Source these weapons or other technical
advice outside the country it may have
to rely on countries like Mali and
Burkina Faso for expertise and also
support from the mercenary group
mercenary groups that have been
operating in these two countries but how
much can they give how long will that be
simply because they too are facing a
similar problem they're trying as much
as they can to reign in these attacks on
their territory and we don't see much
progress in that regard they continue to
witness the East and I think what will
happen in the next few months or so if
this coup survives it will be public
anger directed at the coup plotters in
Nigeria Republic because they will
people will start questioning the
credibility of their uh allegations that
bazoom has failed to reign in insecurity
in that country and it's happening to
them so basically the reason for the one
of the main reasons of the coup may have
been completely eroded
Ahmed something else we want to ask you
about niger's co-leaders have sent their
newly appointed prime minister Ali
Muhammad Zane to neighboring Chad for
talks and he met China's prime minister
in Jamina
Niger maintains that it's open to talks
on solving Regional disputes triggered
by the coup three weeks ago
what what can we make of this visit to
char Ahmed
it could be two things first of all
first of course is to put to to pull
more countries more friends on the side
of the military regime in Miami and
secondly also to sort of keep the hope
that negotiations to end the crisis
diplomatically could is possible now the
prime minister is there we are not sure
exactly what message he took to
president Idris Derby uh Mohammed Idris
Debbie but remember Muhammad Idris
Debbie was a first Envoy who tried to
intervene or tried to mediate between
the coup Waters and the economic
community of West Africa states to sort
this one out or to solve the problem
diplomatically but they turned him back
now whether or not this is another
reprogram or another charm offensive by
the authorities in Niger to try to draw
Chad back into the fold of negotiations
or they're trying to keep as many
friends as they can on their side as
they face International pressure to
restore Muhammad to power remains to be
seen in the next few weeks
thanks for all your reporting and
putting vital context around all of this
that's Ahmed Idris reporting from
katsina in Nigeria and near the border
with Niger